this report that came out not too
terribly long ago that confirmed the
biden administration is putting out low
confidence intel
gossip rumors to the american press
about what's happening
in the ukraine
example
the story that russia was going to
utilize uh in chemical or biological
weaponry uh that story came out in in
february into march there was actually
no intelligence that said that that
would happen now it it could still in
the future or perhaps as we're speaking
it just has but the point is at the
moment when they gave that story to the
american people to the world it wasn't
true so when you start doing that when
you start just pumping out
low confidence information information
that's probably just gossip and rumors
you do this horrible thing of
undermining confidence in the
intelligence community
when you saw the
51 i believe it was
former intelligence officers
who all said that the hunter biden
laptop was russian misinformation or
disinformation they all said it without
having seen it okay
when you saw that so let's go back
before it's been debunked but when it
originally came out i'm talking during
the election when they all came out and
said that conveniently enough right
before the election
what was your take then compared to now
both then and now my reaction was the
same there is absolutely no way to know
unless you do a forensic analysis of
whether or not that laptop a belonged to
hunter biden and b if there was any
additional information added that would
be thus disinformation or propaganda or
part of some sort of covert action op by
the russians the chinese whoever it
might be
so to immediately come out and just
dismiss it
was absurd and what it showed me was
that those people on that list were
partisans they were they were using the
the stink as it were of working at the
cia being an intelligence officer to you
know go out to the american people with
some degree of gravitas like they're
sort of mini james bond or whoever it
might be and so you're going to take
them seriously and so they abused
their professional histories to make
this partisan point and so again we we
saw this by the way not just with the
the hunter
biden laptop we saw this with the steele
dossier that that's perhaps
even more agreed just years prior to
that when i i think you could say
where's the point where we really
started seeing this publicly you had a
whole bunch of intelligence officials
who damn well know better that when you
get information which was what was
inside the steele dossier which is
russia right that you have to tr you
know tread very very cautiously around
russian intel because of the likelihood
that it has been fed in this case to
steal the the british spy
so when you had people saying oh that
this deal dossier is true it's got to be
true that's when i was like all right
this
this whole thing has been cooked the the
this is absolutely members of the ic
wanting to be part of the hillary
clinton administration or the joe biden
administration now who are trying to
gain favor and they're using their
backgrounds to do so and it's just
infuriating because ultimately what
happens and what has happened is the
american people lose faith in the
intelligence community
they lose faith in the law enforcement
community and rightfully so and so when
that happens you've got a whole bunch of
people with lots of profound powers who
don't actually have the support of the
american people they start acting
basically with impunity because they can
it just countries start falling apart
when this stuff happens and that's the
part that that i'm so profoundly afraid
right so i try not to be a crazy
alarmist on this show try maybe i fail
at it but i try not to be but it seems
to me that's kind of where we're at
because when the 51
intelligence
officers in in essence former
propagandist propagandists i was trying
to be nice thank you for cleaning that
up for me yeah you don't have when those
51 propagandists were exposed as such
meaning the new york times finally a
year and a half later everyone knows
this now a month and a half ago or so
finally he said yeah yeah the laptop was
real by the way did anyone get called
into an office did anyone get fired from
a consulting gig they got did anyone get
fired from the lobbying firm or anything
i suspect not and that goes to your
point about the trust it's like
i think they sort of feel i can get away
with anything because they can get away
with anything
yeah
well and there was a report out some
time back that the joe biden
administration has actually encouraged
and allowed this junk
intel to go out about ukraine i mean
all because he wants to try to encourage
the american people to embrace a greater
involvement in the war so you are having
this this intelligence fiasco after
fiasco and at some level i think a
reasonable person says i've had enough
whenever you say american intelligence
assesses i'm not going to believe it and
i can't tell those people right now
particularly with the current leadership
that they're wrong
and that's that's really sad for a guy
who spent most of his life in the world
of intelligence let's shift that a
little bit to what you just mentioned
there so so this russia ukraine
situation i actually have not covered it
a ton on the show i i was very honest
with my audience from the beginning i
was kind of like
this whole thing
reads very weird to me
the whole setup
the biden laptop piece of it
suddenly we all got to hate russia i'm
not defending russia you can't just
invade a sovereign nation but it just
there it just felt like so much
propaganda that i've i've bounced around
it a little bit and i've talked about
the after effects meaning inflation and
gas and things like that and i've tried
to talk about what we should do perhaps
and shouldn't do but i'm not doing the
daily thing with russia and ukraine how
are you able to assess information
properly because i think people are just
you know you put the ukrainian flag in
your twitter avatar everybody else is an
evil nazi that's it i suspect it's not
quite that simple
oh dear no uh so you know you know that
you're caught in a hysteria when and
this is true
both of the major marathons in this
country have banned runners from ukraine
or russia i should say russia or uh
bella russia from running right right so
we're banning marriages not ukraine
because of their national identity right
and we're pouring out you know we're
renaming chicken kiev and it's chicken
keef it's stop all right it's we are
this is hysteria defined
so uh i i think that it's important for
people like me to speak to these issues
around war and peace and including in
ukraine knowing that there is a fog of
war issue so when i talk about ukraine
or any other places around the world i'm
going to be very careful to make sure
that i have medium or high degree of
confidence in what i'm sharing with
people now this issue of confidence is
one that is very familiar to anybody
who's worked in the intelligence
community
you don't put out to policymakers or the
public low confidence information though
confidence information means you haven't
vetted it or the person right you
haven't compared that report that that
spy is giving you to maybe you've
captured an email or a phone call or
you've gotten other spies who are
confirming the same same information so
in other words there's this issue of
confidence you want to give policymakers
medium to high degree of confidence in
your assessments i do that the same uh
they have that same focus that's in
spirit when i talk about the things on
the president's daily brief the podcast
and that's what the intelligence
community should be doing right now on
the issues of ukraine and others but
that's not what's happening again this
report that came out not too terribly
long ago that confirmed the biden
administration is putting out low
confidence intel
gossip rumors to the american press
about what's happening
in the ukraine
example
the story that russia was going to
utilize uh you know chemical or
biological weaponry uh that story came
out in in february into march there was
actually no intelligence that said that
that would happen now it it could still
in the future or perhaps as we're
speaking it just has but the point is at
the moment when they gave that story to
the american people to the world it
wasn't true so when you start doing that
when you start just pumping out
low confidence information information
that's probably just gossip and rumors
you do this horrible thing of
undermining confidence in the
intelligence community and oh by the way
dave we did this before do you remember
in the run-up in the war of uh iraq we
started that war because of weapons of
mass destruction that was the story that
was sold to people we had low confidence
that that was true by the way it was
based on one guy the operation was
curveball and curveball was a big old
liar and it was responsibility and
intelligence community to vet that
person their information to say nope
that was a lie didn't colin powell say
there was a rod i thought colin powell
went in front of congress and said he
saw a rod or something yeah yeah sure
well i'm sure they all saw lots of
things after they were they were wrong
namely their retirements yeah uh but the
the issue is so now the intelligence
community when i was at the cia we all
were burned by that case and we said to
each other particularly the analysts
never again never again are we going to
be allowed to pump out low competence
low confidence garbage intel into the
world because we're going to get
ourselves in trouble again we're going
to cause trillion dollar wars with
hundreds of thousands of people dead
like in iraq or thousands and thousands
of our soldiers and airmen and the rest
who come home without arms and legs and
their minds are broken like that's the
legacy of putting out garbage intel and
joe biden is doing it again in the
ukraine if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell